please be standing for the chairman of
Thanet District Council
thank you please be seated we have had
the windows open for a while but if any
gentlemen would like to remove their
coats do feel free to good evening
members officers of the council and
members of the press and public I
welcome you to this extraordinary
meeting of the council Thursday 19th of
July 2018 housekeeping if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs either through the
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the foyer please do not use
the lifts please assemble in Hawley
square on the green officers will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber I can announce
that the proceedings this meet this of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the Internet I
would also advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present I'll ask the question that I
know the answer does anyone intend to
film the meeting this evening
thank you therefore any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to leave the meeting any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of the business
this evening we're accept exempt or
confidential information is covered
following the exclusion of the press and
public from the meeting would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
calls in the chamber whilst this meeting
is in progress
move on to the agenda now agenda item 1
apologies for absence we've received
apologies from counts
fella counselor Linda pots counselor Roy
pots are there any other apologies for
absence this evening
in that case I'll move on to agenda item
2 announcements can I just say that I
was saddened to hear the appalling
incident that happened this afternoon
when a member of staff was physically
assaulted and I'm sure everyone present
would wish him a speedy recovery
the police are investigating so we can
say no more other than that unfortunate
incident general item three declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest this evening counselor Wells
I missed chairing that traditionally
we've always taken up a cursory
principal with declarations of interest
in this chamber and I just wondered
whether or not we ought to take note and
give the 11 conservative councillors the
opportunity to acknowledge that they
went to a dinner on Saturday evening in
Broadstairs sponsored by a local estate
agent in the few days before they
actually come here to vote on whether or
not there are to be a large number of
houses than we have proposed to date
that it put into our island those
counselors counseled Austin Rogers Evans
Byford Taylor Smith Dexter Pugh
messenger Bainbridge Castleberry
Saunders and yourself mr. chairman who
were present at that dinner and I just
wondered if it's the conscious the
council you would actually take the lead
and make a declaration of interest
in the interest of transparency
I was indeed at that at that dinner it
was dinner organized by the North and
South conservative it's associations I
accepted the invitation on behalf of
South Thanet conservatives as chairman
of the South Lennox Conservatives I was
unaware of who the other guests were
going to be and yes indeed I was quite
surprised that there were a number of
faces that I recognized from the local
business sector but I can assure members
of the chamber this evening that my
table was well away from the business
tables and there were no business
transactions to my knowledge taking
place and I'm sure other members that
were there will confirm exactly the same
but thank you for pointing it out I
would discuss the matter with the
monitoring officer and if necessary I
will fill in the necessary declaration
form thank you so we move on to agenda
item four the main agenda of this
evening which is the Thanet local plan
publication stage regulation 19 and
submission for examination regulation 22
members would have found notes on their
chairs
can I ask do members need to have a few
minutes to digest those notes before we
move on to the main agenda item so I
think if sufficient people are
interested or should we move on in that
case we'll move on and I call upon the
leader
thanks chairman and I'll remind members
that the local plan is the statutory
document that is assessed by an
independent planning inspector it must
be clearly evidence-based purpose of the
local plan is to set out the development
strategy for the district for the period
to 2031 identifying sites to be met
objectively assessed housing employment
and other needs the plan also identifies
areas to protect to be protected from
development such as international
wildlife sites
Green widgets and flood risk areas the
local plan provides a starting point for
considering planning applications and
helps to provide certainty about
development for local people developers
and investors alike just like to remind
members how we got to where we are today
in January the previous administration
tabled a draft local plan which proposed
the mixed reduced allocation on the
Manston Airport site this was rejected
by 35 councillors Audrey non-count saw
that some 48 councillors were elected
having promised to see aviation returned
to Manston if they possibly could the
draft local plan before you tonight
recommended by cabinet leaves the
Menston site unallocated for at least
two years following the adoption of a
new local plan the knowledge in the
current DCO process for the site and
allowing for potential indemnity
partners in a future CPO process to come
forward
it must be stressed the current airport
related policies including ec4 would
remain in force until the new local plan
is adopted and will continue to carry
weight in planning decisions it's
important that there is no further delay
to the local plan process members will
be aware that the ministry for housing
communities and local government is
already assessing the position of the
draft local plan in sanik with the view
to further intervention if the draft
local plan does not proceed in a timely
fashion effectively removing council
control of the process delay also risks
being caught by the proposed change in
the formula used to assess housing need
leading to an increase in our housing
target of over 3000 extra homes I'll
remind members that before us tonight is
a draft local plan to be published for
coming and then submitted for
examination those who agree disagree
with aspects of the plan should make
comment and I would encourage as many
people as want to do that because that
will then give them the opportunity to
make representation in person at the
public inquiry in the meantime I urge
members to support the recommendation
and move the local plan process forward
thank you James I'm sorry I better move
it as
so I remove the recommendations on the
members note which are proposals coming
from cabinet from a parenthesis one
through the parenthesis six by so move
chair thank you
is there a seconder Thank You chairman
I'd like to second that Thank You
councillor savage councillor gross
yes chairman at the moment we are
looking at one option which I believe he
originally we had two options which was
option one and option two so this
council should be debated at these two
options and the option one that are you
read was the officers recommendation not
this one thank you
that's sorry not the cabinet's
recommendation leader would you like to
respond
yeah I'm two options came before cabinet
and off the debate we actually opted for
option two
councillor Campbell oh yes thank you
hopefully no brain fade this evening
just to ensure there isn't I've written
it down I had this on those open for
your benefit okay I suffered the exactly
the same brain sees you last night
okay Thank You chair this afternoon and
again this evening counselor Byford
sought to justify his cabinet adoption
of the overview and scrutiny
recommendations by stating that most
councillors were elected on the promise
that they would return medicine as a
function Airport and they should honor
that promise to their residents now on
the face of it this is a very laudable
statement however what it does not take
into account is the consequence of that
now now in promised this council now
knows and has evidential reports that a
functioning Airport on that site is
unsustainable it has no counter mounting
evidence to the contrary and is not
seeking any why because they know that
that evidence does not exist
so if or shall I say when this council
supports this tammany recommendation we
will have a draft local plane with a
large brownfield site in the middle of
fact unallocated for at least two years
with a consequence of over 2,500 homes
being allocated on greenfield sites
which because of their diverse or okay
will not generate the necessary
infrastructure investment but in local
services under enormous strength upon
public examination the inspector will
have our draft local plan with a large
brownfield site unallocated for at least
two years and are legally required a
brownfield site register which allocates
of that very land for housing locally by
the way this iteration of the local
prayer reduces the percentage of housing
allocated on brownfield sites from 40
percent up from one down to 25 percent
something I am sure the inspector would
take into account upon examination even
though I love government instruction
requires councils to include brownfield
sites first this council is already on a
yellow card from the Department of
Housing communities and local government
for not producing a sound evidence-based
local plan so what are the cabinet
proposing while an unsound not
evidence-based plan for adoption what
makes me think we are heading for a
planning car crash i absorb completely
the senior management team and our
planning team for they have recommended
a sound evidence-based option which has
been rejected by cabinet in conclusion
in conclusion I will ask one question if
oh and I've got two pages stuck together
if this council does adopt the cabinet
proposal this evening does that adoption
it affect me we are formally as a
council rejecting planning application
18 Oh double six Oh the onus of the
site's application for mixed-use
development thank you Thank You
councillor Campbell
councillor brim I think and then
councillor messenger leaders not
standing is not indicated he wants to
respond to that at this moment so
councillor brink Thank You mr. chairman
first of all this evening I'd like to
ask for recorded votes this evening I'm
speaking on behalf of my constituents
solely regarding the local plan and the
overdevelopment of the village of Burton
section three point one sixth of the
councils published local plan document
specifically refers to Burrington as a
village albeit a large one
however in your separate paper titled
housing levels for rural settlements
your paper states the following that a
responsive approach should be taken to
local circumstances in rural areas
regarding the reflection of local need
including thorough rural exception sites
where needed
the paper also states about promoting
sustainable development in rural areas
that will enhance and maintain the
vitality of rural communities the paper
also states that a blanket expansion
should be avoided and less supports
supported by robust evidence the village
real estates that are afforded this
protection are as follows a coal cliffs
end Minster Moncton sint-niklaas Manston
and saw however you have left the
village of Burrington off this list and
we are a rural area by doing so
excessive housing could easily be
foisted upon Burrington which will
result in us becoming a town
I have not campaigned against the
overdevelopment of birching to Nathania
in my role as a member of the public TDC
elected member TDC cabinet member and
vice chairman of campaign to protect
rural England Thanet branch for the last
three and a half years to sit here
tonight to go back on my words I am
therefore requesting that Burton is
afforded the same village status in line
with the surrounding Thanet villages and
I would like this confirmed to me within
a written
response all members parish councillors
district councillors and county
councillors should be fiercely speaking
out about Bertrand's and villages status
failure to do so and you will be
complicit in our beautiful clinic
village turning into a town and my final
comment is that the local plan a lot
like the council's not fit for purpose
Thank You councillor prim before we move
on to council messenger you have
requested a recorded vote so can I get
the consensus of members with regards to
a recorded out our members in agreement
with a recall ago in that case we'll
organize a recorded vote at the end no
you've spoken to council bring this
council messenger now thank you Thank
You mr. chairman
I would like to remind members the MPP F
R guidelines and not statutory whilst I
approve of the change suggested by
overview and scrutiny and adopted by
cabinet today I disapprove of the
housing number that we are subjected to
and I want to reassure Westgate
residents that I will do all that is
within my power to fight the plan that
we have inherited from you Kip
Thank You council s enger' I have
councillor Dixon and then counts the
constant one councillor Dixon Thank You
chairman conferred said the council
meeting just last week a significant
delay could result in further
intervention by the Minister the cost of
any external work would have to be borne
by the council even if there were no
intervention there would be significant
costs to the council in reviewing and
updating the evidence base this could
quite easily cost several tens of
thousands of pounds so why does this
administration insist on going ahead
with an unsound plan think
council Dickson counts the constant time
thank you
I'm also speaking on behalf of some of
my residents obviously this is a hot
topic but I believe we should have a
local plan that's based on adequate
up-to-date and relative relevant
evidence evidence about the economic
social and environmental prospects of
Thanet evidence that in fact responds to
the needs of residents let me repeat
that the needs of residents most of whom
were truly fed up and confused by this
situation the evidence that we should be
looking at should lead us to adopt a
sound local plan sound local plan it's
our duty as counselors our
responsibility to ensure our strategies
for housing are fit for purpose that
they are in fact sound this plan is far
from sound we are I believe in effect
handing over control of our local plan
to the DC hlg and James broken Shia and
after say it's inconceivable to me that
he will aid an unsound plan and what
this does is it kicks the ball into the
long grass and those people here that
need decent jobs they can frankly
whistle for those jobs for a while
longer and those people here that need
decent homes can frankly whistle for
decent homes because we're not in a
position to build them and I'm thinking
particularly of those people that are
rough sleepers those people that are so
for surface and those 71 families that
Leslie gave responded to my question
last week this is an outrageous decision
by this council it's not sound we're
going round and round in it in a muddle
and we need to sort this out and I have
to tell all of you it is our
responsibility as councillors thank you
Thank You councillor Constantine I think
next is council markings and then
councillor reverend powerful and then
councillor bamboos
good evening counselors clear and public
new policies relating to green space
energy and water efficiency and internal
space standards could not be applied in
the event that we lose control of the
plan Thank You councillor Larkins counts
the reverent Stuart Piper and excuse me
if I get you out of order but I've got
lots of names on the list but I'll get
round to you all in due course Thank You
Council - Thank You chair
we are not planners that is an obvious
statement but if I then take us back to
January we weren't planners then either
but 35 of us felt that what was being
proposed in January also was unsound I
would refer members and officers to the
many items of Correspondence which were
available to be read on the council's
website from southern water who did not
fully support the idea the Environment
Agency the Highways Agency the military
Dover District Council and Kent County
Council who announced they were at that
time 39 million pounds short of the bill
required to meet the infrastructure
progress process so I'm one who does not
believe that the decision we took in
this place in January was wrong what I
believe we took the right decision to
try and do better leader you mentioned
that we are where we are I'd like to add
a little bit to that we are where we are
and we are in a hole and the first thing
about when you're in a hole stop digging
this council elected members and what
we've been doing since 2011 has been
digging a hole that he's bigger and
bigger and bigger and eventually we will
not be able to get out of it so the
government will take over and they'll
send us sort of a half-hearted attempt
at a rope ladder or something I'm sure
to get us out we have to stop digging we
to make a decision I personally do not
believe this is the best local plan we
could have but I also believe it's
better than the one we were given in
January for consideration I further
believe that it is time we put a marker
in the sand at the moment we have no dog
in the fight we are not part of the
process really we need to get something
out for publication for public comment
we need to get the inspector looking at
what we're doing and the changes we've
tried to make since that appalling
effort in January finally I - do not
blame officers for the situation that
we're in whether you like it or not
leader it is the leader who sets policy
with his or her cabinet and officers
implement it we have been told that many
times therefore the situation we arrived
at in January was not the fault of the
officers Thank You Jimmy Thank You
Council Piper point well spoken
councillor Bainbridge Thank You chair I
want it noted that I believe the logic
of facing an important part of your
local plan covering aviation on an
out-of-state spurious untested piece of
work such the Avery report that clearly
contradicts the recent MPP F and
national aviation policy urge in
protection of airports and local plans
defies belief as does the questionable
credibility of advice saying to retain
an aviation policy is unlawful
especially in light of the recently
submitted D Co and I just want to give
everybody a little bit of history so
that we know why we are where we are in
2015 48 t DC councillors were elected on
a promise to support the airport from
August 2015 councillor Wells backed out
of his promise and led a determined
effort to designate Manston for housing
this was bound to end in defeat as it
did on the 18th of January because the
majority of councillors were determined
to keep their promise that they made to
their voters councilor worlds had nearly
three years in which to produce local
plan which met the wishes of the voters
and he failed the inevitable result was
the intervention from the ministry in
the unseemly pressure now being placed
on this council councillor Welles
deliberately flouting the wishes of the
voters is directly responsible for why
we are
where we are today however all right we
are where we are and we must do what we
must do in order to ensure the best case
scenario for Monson Airport in this case
option two is that best case scenario
and although I am deeply unhappy that we
have been unable to reintroduce my bus
genuine aviation policy sp0 five
incorporating ec4 into the draft due to
officer advice I have no choice than to
vote for option two as the only option
that gives some protection to the
airport and I sincerely hope my fellow
councillors with respect to their
lecturer of the mind to do the same
Thank You council bambridge councillor
Wells you have been named would you like
to respond yes I agree with the first
instinct there that is you have officers
who implement policy on behalf of
counselors and leaders and cabinet the
problem we now have quite simply
straightforwardly is the policy that
should be put forward by the leader in
the cabinet doesn't exist can't be
evidence so what is in its place is a
series of words which carry no weight
and no defense at the airport whatsoever
in defense of that position many of the
conservative councilors say quite simply
don't worry about the exchanging numbers
on greenfield sites because we could
reverse that in the future as when the
DCO arrives the military has already
specifically warned his council against
putting too much reliance on the DCI and
actually that logic worked in Reverse if
you are that certain your reverse things
in the future what you could do will be
to put the houses on Manson reverse that
in the future and save two and a half
thousand houses worth of greenfield site
and I'm sure the kotas of Westgate are
going to take that into account
Thank You councillor Wells Council in
Fairbrass Thank You chairman councillor
Piper has just displayed the fact that
he still doesn't understand the Local
Plan process but appalling offer from
January's actually what we have now and
some an option was given before that
vote that actually gave a two year
window before
policy SPO five kicked in which would
have protected the site but this option
deletes any relevant policy for the
airport site giving no protection
whatsoever based on its own evidence the
council cannot justify a no policy
stance advice from counsel has
constantly been that a site this size
with no policy will render the plan
unsound I cannot and will not add my
name to a proposal that will probably
cost this council tens of thousands of
pounds thank you I have councillor Crowe
brown on my list next Thank You chair I
was one of those that stood on the man
stand ticket indeed I was based at RAF
man stand on two occasions in 80s and
90s I saw how much the mo D used to have
to pay for that site electricity bills
thousands per month now yeah I would say
that I was fortunate to be on the local
plan working group and I have the utmost
admiration for the strategic working
group the Planning Group the legal
advice we had both internally and
externally and I for one will not waste
public money so I won't support this
option to indeed allied to the loss of
control of the plan there is a
significant risk to the provision of
Kane's restructure to support
development roads schools health
facilities etc so why are we going to
risk this with this unsound plan thank
you Thank You councillor Allen council
Pugh Thank You chairman and it's amazing
that the you cube group are advocating
or well coming out in support of trying
to stop a No Deal for once it's them
it's quite interesting and and I'd like
to refer to Council well so the fact of
their charity ball that 11 are Scouts
councillors attended at the weekend you
know happy to declare it if I need to my
desmond state agent I'll happily to
clear that and I'm into Crompton's
recently but I'll declare that if I need
to and the main issue that I'd like to
raise is that I'd like to reiterate what
the counselors for Westgate have said I
disagree with the housing numbers and I
will do everything I can to dispute and
stop
the amount of houses that proposed for
the villages we don't need them is as
simple as that and the integrity of the
villages needs to be saved the integrity
of the villages needs to be saved it's
as simple as that and if we destroy
Manston we'll never get it back
Thank You members can I remind members
to stick through the agenda we've
already discussed a certain pavilion
event would you like to respond you've
been named again councillor whirls thank
you in that case councillor hunter
Thank You chairman I have a question for
our leader council de Beauford you said
with the loss of control over new
development there is a greater risk that
development will take place on a more
unplanned basis so why is this
administration putting forward a plan
that is likely to be found
unsound thank you well I've refute that
the plan being put forward is unsound
but I think the point being made that
without a current local plan then we
find it much more difficult to control
development in places we don't want it
apologies hunter my mouth is extremely
dry I've got councillor Venables now
kind of the claim with my colleague
councillor messenger over here who is
going to oppose houses being built in
Westgate I do I live in this game I'm
wondering what councillors in in this
chamber will actually be advocating for
those houses to be built in their own
wards when most people seem to be
opposed to those those houses being
built and we have an option for them
being built elsewhere on Olive Belford
site I just wondered who is going to be
saying let's have them here Thank You
council in the balls
I've got councillor wells and then
councillor Johnson council wells okay
brake very straightforward because I
think you know week that week appear all
evening at if we're not careful castle
campbell at scrutiny said something very
straightforward and very simple but I
think we need to take into account at
this point we have a long and esoteric
debate on what the difference was
between the terms illegal an unsound in
local plan terms there is no doubt that
option two is not illegal may because it
doesn't actually say anything the words
that are in it have no policy base they
have no evidence base it
is a form of words and aspiration rather
than anything that you can firmly base
any real decision up however if that is
so and it is so then what we are
proposing is an unsound plan and I doubt
they'll ever get the public examination
I suspect that mr. broken sure and his
team will be in and telling us what to
do long before we get to that point and
that will be because there are too many
counselors in this chamber who like
happened before with live animal exports
it will not listen to professional
advice and would rather listen to their
own personal and private beliefs Thank
You councillor Wells councillor Johnson
thank you very much chairman in response
to the final remark by councillor Wells
it was actually the professional advice
of officers here that led to the closure
of the port not the advice of elected
members I was here I know what happened
so we'll move on from that one it was an
officer of this council who said he
needed to close the port he had a duty
of Culture Johnson come to you all you
want to talk about is the airport this
is a huge document this document was
ready in January 2015 and ready to be
finished by September 2015 with final
consultation that January 2015 our labor
administration had a working party
looking exclusively at the airport site
we left it as an airport in that next
election but some of us knew we had done
our best not just in the four years from
the time we took control of the three
years we had done it all our political
lives in here to support has had many at
KCC of all political colours funding was
allocated etc in 2010 there was a
coalition government the coalition
government told us to hold fire on
everything we were doing with planning
because they had some new ideas for us
so we have you were conservative council
you were the leader we had to hold fire
in 2011 we were told to hold fire well
into 2012 it went on and on and on the
airport was eventually bought as we all
know by mrs. Globes were one pound and
if then she decided she wasn't going to
offer
in Airport we then had to look at
something else I phoned the aviation
Minister Robert Goodyear and he was very
nice to me but he said such a shame
airports are closing all over the
country I went to see an Globe and the
3rd of July 2014
I spoke with everybody I included all
political leaders in every meeting that
I had so that you knew what was going on
we did our best to save the airport by
the time we lost control of the council
let us say we left it as an airport but
you didn't meet as a working group ever
again since which you should have done
I'm sorry you must allow me to finish
I've kept quiet at every meeting about
this for months the truth is this we did
our best
you are now going to have more housing
than you ever thought we were crucified
in meetings in Westgate and watching
tanaya's we were told we had to have
there how are people going to feel with
the extra you're now being told to put
in the infrastructure is a disaster in
town are already doctor surgeries are
closing we could lose our stroke unit we
want to look at this document as a whole
you want to look at the pollution that
can be brought in by having I'm sorry
everybody but a cargo airport
I used Manston for passenger I fought
tooth and nail for it I contacted the
family in Ireland who originally owned
the land I did everything possible to
save that Airport but even I with my
passion could not do it
this document must be approved the dog's
dinner that you've produced this evening
to ask us to vote on is taking us back
five years sorry
leader sorry nearly finished thank you
well I think council resetti sorry
Thank You chair just a quick couple of
words having listened to the debate
tonight I see that labor obviously want
to build houses on the site yet claim
they want jobs how are you going to get
jobs out I don't know because I was sure
there'll be big companies that would be
coming down from London and producing
little caravan villages around the place
and building housing if that was the
case my old outfit obviously didn't want
the airport at its highest levels
otherwise we could have achieved that no
problem
when we had control of the council
council Byford has listened to what the
independents have said and has adjusted
some of the wordings to help us move
along and get the airport we do need the
airport here in plan it it will bring
the jobs that planet needs and it's the
best thing and the only thing that can
be used on the mountainside thank you
Jeff councillor Evans
yes councillors ERV be sure that what
you're voting on tonight is this is
giving us the self determination to
carry on with this what we do at the
moment if you vote against it it will be
taken out of our hands and then we have
no saying it whatsoever
I know the houses are unpalatable but it
doesn't take a genius to work out that
30% of our population will be retired in
10 years in 20 years that 30% will be
dying off these houses will never be
built be sure that okay so what you're
voting on tonight is a straight vote for
people and local playing in our own
hands or washing their hands with it and
letting the men for ministry take over
it's as simple as that
then houses will never be built because
we've got an aging population Thank You
councillor Evans
councillor jeremy Fairbrass Thank You
chair ah good evening members council de
Beauford has said all the time there is
no adopted local plan there is a
significant risk that the council cannot
demonstrate a five-year housing supply
if this occurs the council would lose
the ability to refuse housing
applications in undesirable locations or
could face an increased risk of losing
planning appeals and consequently
greater risk of costs being granted
against the cash-strapped council so why
is this administration proceeding with
an unsound plan thank you Thank You
councillor Fairbrass we've had some
passionate debate yes counselor I'd just
like to remind members that yes I was
elected to save Madison Airport but I
was also elected to reduce housing
figures in Westgate if I were to survey
the majority of West residents in
Westgate
they would all say that they would
rather reduce housing figures as opposed
to mountain air pool now that aside to
me to admit so I want both but I know
that I can't have both
now I must represent my electorate and I
stood on a platform with counts the
whales and we promised to reduce housing
figures in Westgate now I don't believe
these calculations are viable I feel
we're using out-of-date data I've seen
data today from mid 2017 that suggests
there's more deaths in sanik than births
so I feel that the population is
reducing so I'm quite happy for the
housing calculations to be redone and
hopefully we get reduced housing numbers
that's why I cannot support the draft
Local Plan Thank You council day
I think one of the main things that
brings us all to support man snare but
when we do and we need to think more of
it in national terms as well is this a
strategic asset to this country since
the first report was put out we voted to
leave Europe we need the airport to be
able to get our goods in and out of the
world and be able to trade I think
that's more important than village
numbers of housing because it's such a
national strategic piece of
infrastructure and I I'll do everything
I can to support medicine Airport and
give it the best chance of surviving in
its current state or in the new state we
hope it's been thinking Thank You
Council day I think we've had quite
robust debate on a very emotive subject
so leader I'll hand it back to you and
then we can get on what we've called it
vote thank you yeah Thank You chairman I
just want to respond to a couple of
points that were made well I think one
of the points to be made is that this
administration has only been in power
for four months there are six years of
other administration's prior to that so
I think that the fact that we've moved
this to where it is today is something
of an achievement obviously it's quite
it's quite interesting that you know
outside people always saying world the
council's run by officers you know
members just do as they're told but here
tonight quite clearly everybody's saying
that well the officers knew what I was
doing some members that were wrong you
know the members for but I think what in
fact happened and I'd like to thank the
officers for this I'm very conscious
that option one was their preferred
option but they did recognize that
members had an opportunity to take part
in the shaping of the local plan and
this administration wished to shape it a
slightly different way and I thank them
for the support they've given us in
doing that it's interested in as well
that you know what's had been around for
four months after two weeks of being
leader of this council received a letter
of congratulations for sent from
Javad also tell we were in to
intervention at that point in time so
you know the intervention was a
responsibility of someone else but here
we are and when the men from the
ministry came in I made it abundantly
clear that their primary objective was
to ensure that the local plan was
produced in a timely fashion and I think
we've responded to that admirably
counselor Constantine talks about the
brings in rough sleepers and so on I
just like to remind her that the
government has granted discounts with
three hundred sixty seven thousand
pounds to address that problem and I
would refer to my leaders report with
the last counts or where I actually
outlined the success of the winter
shelter so I think we're doing very well
in combating that particular problem of
course people have got different views
to us about this I would urge them to
take advantage of the opportunity to go
along you know put comments in in the
comment stage in the publication stage
and to go along to the public inquiry
make their points known because that's
where this plan will finally take shape
I can't let council Fairbrass get away
with the suggestion that we had an
option on the table in Council it wasn't
in house you know no no count you're
giving the impression that council
reject the leader speak please Thank You
councillor Fairbrass has given the
impression that this council
representatives Ric refused some kind of
moderated option grant option one and
that wasn't the case it just wasn't true
so in fact option one was where you were
option two is where we are now I don't
have a same conclusion is that most
members here tonight were elected on a
pledge to do what they could to bring
aviation back to Menston voting for
tonight's recommendation gives us the
chance to honor that pledge members
let's do the right thing
thank you no counsel was summing up I'm
told to agree move straight on to the
recorded votes I'll ask the monitoring
officer to do record if they were
thinking in that case counselor
Fairbrass thank you can't see food
you're very well aware that there was a
second option that was circulated and it
was in the public domain that there was
a policy set for SPO 5 which was able to
be deferred for two years it was sent
round to every every group in this
council and none of the groups apart
from the labor group would support that
so there was no point in putting that to
the council on the night of the boat so
I'd like you to retract that that it's
not true please maybe
no maybe my machine goes back to the
cabinet meeting this afternoon because
it was pointed out to me by somebody
else that the suggestion had been made
if you're you weren't making that
suggestion then I'm not calling you a
liar thank you can we now move on to a
recorded vote I'll ask the monitoring
officer to read out your names thank you
the the proposal is with regards to the
notes that you found on your chair this
evening and as read out by the leader at
the beginning of the debate and that's
from 1 through 2 6 so that's what we're
voting on monitoring officer thank you
then carat the recorded vote Casa Ashby
that's a bainbridge that's AB a foot
that's a Braidwood that's a brim Casa
Buckley as a Campbell councillor Glenn
Coleman cook Casa Keith Coleman cook
Casa Connor Casa Constantine councillor
crow Brown Casa Curran Casa Dawson
Council a de casa della counselor Denis
counselor Dexter councillor Dixon Casa
Edwards councillor Evans councillor
Jeremy Fairbrass Council in Fairbrass
that's a falcon Castle game cats a
Gregory that's a Grove Castle hatin
Castle Hillman Council Jay Jones Casa
Johnston NASA Larkins Casa Martin
counter matter face casts a messenger
Casa Parsons counselor Linda Piper
counselor Reverend Stewart Piper
counselor pew castle of Rogers Katsaros
ecchi councillor David Saunders cancer
amazed Saunders Kathir savage counselor
shank cancerous tumors purchasing
counselor Taylor grief counselor Taylor
Smith counselor Tomlinson counselor
Townend
causa Venables now so Wells thank you
that's 31 verses 21 propose was agreed
thank you and that now concludes the
business for the meeting of the council
this evening thank you very much for
attending thank you